We can no longer satirize Fox News because
they are beyond satire.
Fox News is now a parody of itself down to
the last detail, including the host wearing
a gigantic, gaudy cross necklace on the eve
of Easter.
I'm talking about depraved, diabolical and
delusional.
Fox News host Jeanine Pirro.
She may this weekend have hosted the most
weaponised single episode of a Fox News program
ever.
We've got the Corona virus pandemic reaching
a fever pitch.
Two thousand Americans a day are dying.
We have no idea how to prevent a second wave
in the fall unless we just keep the shutdown
going.
Disinformation about the virus is spreading
faster than ever.
And on the eve of Easter, Judge Jeanine was
able to put a slate of guests together that
puts previous Fox News propaganda to shame.
Judge Jeanine Waring, again, a comically oversized
cross necklace.
Of course, it was the day before Easter invited
Donald Trump, Trump propagandist Peter Navarro,
who's been spreading endless this information
about the virus.
And Republican Congresswoman Marsha Blackburn,
a top right wing bomb thrower who never came
across alive.
She wasn't willing to tell.
It's not clear if Judge Jeanine was drunk
during this episode.
She was drunk during an episode a week or
two ago.
But you almost had to be drunk for this television
to be tolerable.
And what is with the Godi crosses?
By the way, I just don't understand that.
Here is some of the highlights.
Let's dig right into it.
Trump talking about reopening the economy,
saying it will be based on facts, but also
on instinct, which is really scary.
The Trump seems to have some of the worst
instincts of world leaders and American presidents.
Here is Judge Jeanine teeing up a softball
for Trump and Trump, answering it as if he
is the great thinker that he believes himself
to be.
When you make that decision.
I mean, where do you go within you?
What is it that you dig deep for, to come
up with a decision?
Aside from all of the people surrounding you.
Well, you know, I think it's going to be the
toughest decision that I've ever made.
You know, I really hopefully that I ever will
have to make, but it's certainly the toughest
decision that I've ever made.
And I hope that I'm going to make the right
decision.
I'll be basing it on a lot of a lot of very
smart people, a lot of professionals, doctors
and business leaders.
There are a lot of things that go into a decision
like that.
And it's going to be it's going to be based
on a lot of facts and a lot of instinct also
favor you, whether we like it or not.
There is a certain instinct to it, but we
have to get our country back.
Trump will be deciding on instinct.
That's really, really bad.
And we should be horrified by that, because
Trump's instinct was we would have 15 cases
which would quickly go to zero.
This would wash away like a miracle in April.
Not that we would have tens of thousands of
deaths already.
So then incomes.
Trump's economic adviser, Peter Navarro Navarro,
has been going around and media recommending
medications for Corona virus.
He's an economist and a highly partisan bomb
thrower, certainly not qualified to recommend
medications.
But he goes on Fox News and does exactly that,
including even recommendation recommendations
for specific doses of medication.
Take a look.
And then we went to some additional cities
down the line.
A lot of them we read like NFL franchises.
He I Baltimore, it's Washington, it's Houston.
And also in addition, the Veterans Administration
asked for a million doses.
We got that to them.
And D.O.D. wanted different part of partner
defense wanted it.
How a million doses we got, though, to them.
So there's a demand out there and there's
a protocol.
And let me just say one thing.
The protocol in the FDA is very clear what
they're doing.
It's a five day protocol.
You take a double dose the first day, next
four days, a single dose.
And I think we'll avoid let's see what the
scientific evidence says.
Of course, they're talking interchangeably
about chloroquine and Zithromax.
I believe when he says double dose one day,
followed by a single doses, that's your typical
Z pack, which appears not to work in conjunction
with chloroquine and can actually cause cardiac
issues.
And when Peter Navarro says protocol, Fox
News viewers will hear that and think this
is something that's been actually tested for
and calibrated for Corona virus.
It hasn't.
Typical zie pack is 2 250 milligram tablets
on day one, followed by one tablet.
On days two to five for use as an antibiotic
to treat bacterial infections.
When Peter Navarro says this is the protocol,
people will hear it and they'll think that's
the protocol for Corona virus, which of course
it is not.
And in fact, we have yet another pre-print
of a peer reviewed study which says that short
term chloroquine treatment is safe.
When you add a zero myson, it can cause heart
failure and cardiovascular mortality that
is also separate from whether it even works.
Unkovic, 19.
And that data remains unclear.
And then we go to Congresswoman Marsha Blackburn
using language that to the average Fox News
viewer will imply China sent the virus possibly
as a bio weapon.
Now, one of the things I think should happen
with the U.N. Human Rights Council and the
W.H.O., my goodness, here we have China being
protected by the W.H.O. and then they're wanting
to have this seat on the U.N. Human Rights
Council.
Maybe it's time to review the funding that
we send to them.
Maybe it is time to send that message.
Is that what China did?
Listen, China is not our friend.
They are our enemy.
They haven't been ripping us off, taking our
jobs.
They have been sending the US, this virus
this year.
They've been stealing our intellectual property.
And we need to realize they are not our friend.
They are part of the new axis of evil.
You've got North Korea and China and Iran
and Russia.
And Judge, these are not people who wish us
well.
So a few things there.
And of course, the ignorance is stunning to
the average Fox News viewer when you say China
sent us the virus.
It's going to sound to them like this was
a bio weapon.
Number two, Blackburne has this incredibly
simplistic understanding of foreign policy
with her whole.
China's our enemy and they are aligned with
North Korea.
There is no doubt.
And I've talked about it.
The Russia, China, North Korea situation is
one of concern.
But the thinking she outlines here in relation
to the virus.
OK.
So if we call China the enemy, then what?
What about Trump's laughable handling of the
virus?
So if we called China the enemy, then where
do we get on our caseload?
It was so bizarre.
Even Judge Jeanine seems confused by it at
one point.
She also may have been drinking.
We just don't know.
There's also been a resurgence in the era
of Corona virus with Fox News just carrying
water for Donald Trump.
You might remember that over the few months
before the virus, we were actually saying,
you know, Fox occasionally will do something
other than merely parroting Trump's talking
points and repeating them.
Rare, but it happened.
Fox News is fully back on board with Trump
now.
It's very dangerous.
It's putting people's lives in danger on a
day to day basis.
And Judge Janine's show on Saturday night.
One of the worst that I've seen and it is
now beyond parody.
You can't parody it because the parody is
not as crazy as what is
actually taking
place
on Fox News.